ces went full virtual this year but that
didn't stop companies from showing off
the latest in tech gadgets and
entertainment from across the world but
what does that mean
for the gamers among us well we've gone
ahead and gathered up a few of the most
exciting or interesting announcements
and we've got everything from giant 8k
tvs to rgb face masks with even more
coming soon so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on that
now ces doesn't focus too much on actual
video games more on the tech that drives
them and the way we interact with our
entertainment systems but during sony's
stream it did show off some exciting
release dates for some upcoming titles
this includes kana bridge of spirits
releasing this march
solar ash coming june ghostwire tokyo
and stray
that's the adorable cat game we all fell
in love with e3 last year are both
dropping
this october and project atheia is
coming in january 2022.
however pragmata capcom's mysterious
weird astronaut game that we've not
heard a peep out of
since e3 2020 is in fact getting delayed
until 2023
so it'll be a while longer until we can
figure out what's going on with the
strange sky glitches and the android cat
that were teased
seven long months ago on the pc side
though there is some cool expanded
support for some current games with
rainbow six siege and overwatch being
added to the list of games that can make
use of nvidia's reflex tech
reflex reduces latency by combining
optimizations between both the gpu and
the games themselves
and while it's not a huge draw for fps
fans right now it's cool to see that
nvidia has its eyes on the horizon and
this is a system the company is keen to
support for a good while
rather than a gimmick or experiment that
gets hung out to dry
and there's exciting news for everyone
still feverishly trying to get their
hands on nvidia's latest generation of
graphics cards
during ces nvidia revealed its fourth
graphics card in the growing rtx 30
series line
the new 30 60 card is the cheapest in
the range
while still delivering some impressive
performance numbers although considering
that the 3060 ti was only released back
in december
it is a slightly strange offering many
of the rtx 30 cards are as rare as
rocking horse poop
and have been selling out in the blink
of an eye so it's good to see that
there's more powerful hardware coming
down the line
especially as this card is going to be
launching at 329 usd
and boasts twice the performance of the
old gtx 1060 which
is a big step in allowing more gamers to
make the most of all the lovely new ray
tracing and dlss options
available in recent games with 12
gigabytes of gddr6
over 3500 nvidia cudicores and clocking
in
at 1.78 gigahertz this is again
a lot of power for a really decent price
and also matches nvidia's aim for the
3060 to bring their new architecture
to every gamer and exciting news for
anyone who prefers their pc gaming on
the go
or just favors a slimmer form factor for
their machines
nvidia is bringing its 30 series gpus
into the next generation of laptops
these lappies are built on the latest
ampere architecture and 3rd gen max q
performance
and stress optimization technology which
will hopefully mean that you can pump
out higher frames per second without
your system's fans taking off
or your laptop setting fire to your
thighs laptops equipped with the 360 are
reported to allow for 90 fps gameplay
with ultra settings at 1080p
and these will be starting at 999 3070
laptops are said to be 1.5 faster than
the rtx 2070 gpu
and allow for 90 fps action with ultra
settings on many games at 1440p
obviously the price is a little ramped
up here at 1300
and lastly the 3080 equipped laptops
have 16 gigabytes of gddr6
and can push gameplay past 100 fps with
ultra settings
at 1440p as expected though these models
are going to set you back a few more
bucks
starting around 2 000 but it's not just
gamers that nvidia are trying to cater
to though stating that this performance
is for both work and play
with their studio laptop models and
whatever branded agencies you have
you'll surely have something to suit
your tastes as there are over
70 of these laptops launching later this
month and these of course come from all
the usual suspects like acer
asus rog and razer and speaking of the
mean green snake shape machine razer
showed off some
peculiar concepts during this year's ces
on top
of all the laptop announcements most
notable is an immersive gaming chair
with a
60 inch oled screen which i'm almost
certain will be the first step to us
becoming those floating chair humans
from wally there's also a smart
n95 face mask that not only protects you
and those around you but allows you to
apply
gamer rgb to your own face project
brooklyn is their concept what they're
calling a truly immersive gaming station
which comes complete with an
oled surround screen is built with
carbon fiber is covered in rgb lighting
and is designed around
a full cockpit experience i would say it
looks like an intense piece of kit but
i'm sitting here in front of three
computer monitors so i can't really
critique when it comes to gaming battle
station design but moving on to project
hazel razer's smart mask this is
something i am really quite
interested in despite it being in only a
conceptual stage
a surgical n95 made of clear plastic
featuring wireless charging
voice amplification rechargeable
ventilators uv sterilization
and again the ability to light up my
face in whatever colored lighting i want
honestly sign me up i must say though
that some of the reactions
are gold shout out to mr kepling's
comment on our youtube video
i could finally breathe in 60 fps
is absolutely fantastic although i think
we can all accept that masks aren't
going to go anywhere anytime soon so
it's pretty cool
to see razer applying some of its
ingenuity to them they've been providing
frontline workers with masks since the
pandemic started but if they're going to
start selling something that lets me
dress up my face as if i'm one of the
cyberpunk 2077 npcs then i really am
all for it there was also a big showing
on the monitor and tv front as well
which makes a lot of sense now that the
new generation of gpus from both amd and
nvidia are out in the wild and gamers
are getting their hands on the new
playstation 5
and xbox series x's naturally the best
way to see all those beautiful pixels in
buttery smooth frames are via
a nice shiny monitor or television asus
announced three
new gaming monitors the tough gaming
vg28uq
l1a the rog swift xg43
and the rg swift pg32uq all names that
are
really totally memorable and just roll
off the tongue
but as they feature hdmi 2.1 and 4k
support
they do at least seem to be good options
for console gaming as well
as being part of your pc battle station
if the big screen is more your bags
samsung
sony tcl and lg all got to showcase
their cutting edge tvs
everything from 99 inch screens and 8k
resolutions
across all of these offerings so you can
be sure your games will look the best
they can be
personally the part i get excited about
is that whenever all these super fancy
tvs get announced and their prices are
showing off later down the line
some older but still fantastic
televisions get reduced in price
so make sure you keep your eyes open for
some bargains shout out to the gamespot
deals twitter over the next few months
now that's all we've got time for in
this video but be sure to check out our
full ces coverage on gamespot.com to
read more about
everything you've seen here as well as a
few things we've missed
if you enjoyed the video click the like
button let us know what you're most
excited about in the comment section
below
and we will see you in the next one
[Music]
so
[Music]
you